CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman is
with us Ricky you've prosecuted a sex
crime cases with adults and children
headlines out of the acosta a press
conference seemed to be no apology and
also he says he proceeded appropriately
given the context back then do you agree
not a bit and nothing he said changed my
mind
when he talks about the fact that the
environment for women was different in
2007 than it is in 2019
these are children for heaven's sake
there is no way that we treated as
prosecutors children differently in 2007
than in 2019 our job was to protect them
our job was to get them ready for trial
I not only prosecuted these cases I in
2007 I'm serving on the board of the
rape treatment center in California in
Los Angeles we made sure that child
victims felt supported we didn't just
send an FBI agent or a cop out to see
them and they said I don't want to go
through with this and then just say okay
and that's what happened here Ricky I
want to look at some reporting with the
Miami Herald did about this secret plea
deal that Acosta negotiated with Jay
Lefkowitz
Epstein's lawyer who is a former
colleague of Acosta and they reported
that it cost aloud Epstein's lawyers
unusual freedom and dictating the terms
of the non-prosecution agreement
how unusual do you think it is I think
it's unusual because he was intimidated
by the strength of these lawyers you
have to remember there was Ken Starr
there there was Alan Dershowitz there
you know these are hard cases I agree
that's maybe the one thing I agree with
Acosta about that they're hard cases
well when I was a young prosecutor and I
mean young we relish the idea that the
best and the toughest and the ones with
the great reputation defense lawyers
were coming in because we wanted to try
cases against them we were not
intimidated Acosta called it a roll of
the dice but there was a 53 page
indictment prepared well by the way all
trials are a roll of the dice
you can never guarantee a jurors verdict
but the time is that that's your job
what he did you know there was
statute of limitations here at sex
trafficking at that time so what he did
is he takes a non-prosecution agreement
agreement and shuts it down
for heaven's sake Jeffrey Berman now in
the Southern District of New York talk
about the opposite he's calling for
victims to come forward
there was no urgency they didn't have to
do a non-prosecution agreement do you
have dozens of victims here you have a
cost of delaying telling them about this
plea deal and them seeking restitution
what do you think of that well the judge
in Florida judge Mara has declared that
that was illegal the judge in Florida is
trying to find a sanction against the
government so I don't think that we can
take mr. Acosta's word for this and I'm
very glad that the Palm Beach State's
Attorney came out and said look he
wasn't Superman this is my words not his
he didn't get on his cape and fly over
and save the day to be a hero he tried
to portray himself as him on the
contrary it sounds like you're saying he
wasn't up to the job I think he was not
all right Ricky Kleeman thank you so
much for being with us Rickey